my first three investments were Facebook
Twitter and Tumblr so I'm in that I'm
friends with zux friends with Travis
from uber on you know crush it just came
out and it's killing everything's going
great I'm at the height I'm one of 20
most follow people on Twitter and
Twitter is just starting to matter me
and my brothers start a client service
business like a not super sexy like eat
[ __ ] from clients all day right and so
nobody could have raised more money than
me in 2009 and 10 I'm at the top of my
game and I took four steps back
including being ridiculed and made fun
of by my internet famous friends I went
built vaynermedia we kind of struggled
with it for the first two years cuz it
was hard it was a big humble pie that I
had to eat I to go into brand manager
meetings and it was crazy for where I
was in my career but I was self-aware to
know what I was capable of building that
would be successful and in the 48 months
since I've really run it it's been alive
for six years I've grown that company
from 30 to 650 employees from 3 to 100
million dollars in revenue right and not
passed through revenue of media like we
do 100 millions right and in current 2.5
to 3 time revenue valuations for
agencies it's a 250 to 300 million
dollar valuation with a business that's
gonna kick seventeen million dollars in
profit this year now me and my brother
and my partner right and that one you
can clap because that was real execution
in the face of a lot of sexy other
things to do in the face of and I wasn't
a kid I'd already made it and I still
went practical the level of practicality
the level of self-awareness the level of
patience the level of humility the level
of empathy to the market and gratitude
for your opportunities and the level of
understanding what's happening in the
macro and micro economic climate in our
space is [ __ ]
you